la princesse diana continue de fasciner
un quart de siècle après sa mort dont le
film spencer au met en scène sa détresse
lors des fêtes de noël 1991 au palais de
sandringham quelques mois avant son
divorce c'est une fable surréaliste
mais et tout n'était pas autrement dit
tels que l'histoire le dit cependant le
message lui le message d'ensemble était
vrai trompé par son prince isolé et
prisonnière d'une famille royale au
style rigide et lugubre lady die par l'
équilibre temps de s'accrocher à ses
fils et de reprendre sa liberté et elle
représentait
le souffle de vérité de spontanéité de
naturel le film dit aussi qu'elle avait
des problèmes d'équilibré psychologique
ce qui est vrai c'est pas la seule
donnée en cause mais on lui dit bien on
le décrit bien
le réalisateur chilien pablo larrain à
qui on doit le film jackie propose ici
une fable qui révèle le trouble
intérieur de la princesse des coeurs
incarné par l'américaine kristen stewart
elle est extraordinaire c'est une lady
die plus vrai que vrai son regard son
jeu sa sensibilité sont ses émotions
tout passe dans son regard nostalgique
triste mais mon dieu qu'on étouffe dans
ce but on est sous pression tout le
temps tout le temps avec elle et c'est
on voit qu'elle est adulé adoré par tout
le monde sauf par ses proches les images
sont superbes comme s'est tenue la
princesse d'écart était une icône de la
mode elle bouleverser les codes qui
contrastait avec l'austère famille
windsor les dida c'était une rebelle
elle a toujours un peu de défier défier
la monarchie et des filles qu'elles
étaient les règles et ça se faisait
encore une fois par le vêtement si on y
pense comme il faut on a peu de
de souvenir concret où elle parlait mais
pourtant on a l'impression de la
connaître si bien et si à cause des
vêtements ce qu'elle a réussi à faire
c'est vraiment par son amour de la mode
de trouver le moyen de communiquer
madone
ils vous attendent les contes de fées
fascine et à plus forte raison lorsque
l'on sait qu'il se termine sur un drame
ici nabi alexandre chartier radio canada
montréal
[Musique]